[Music]
chanting I got to ask you about this you
made a cameo in the movie this is the
end
you played yeah you played the [ __ ] I
believe is the character's name there he
is
[Applause]
really really really and describe the
role you probably had too much to drink
the night that I got this email at like
three in the morning I think they were
already filming and I don't know why I
even picked it up and then I read the
emails from Seth Rogen he doesn't email
me and he's like hey I hope this isn't
insulting but I had we had this idea on
the set for a cameo and it involves you
dynamic bride
and a Mexican wrestling max mask and a
leash and I think just I was just like
most of it on ambien and drunken I was
like yeah yeah I'll do it no problem and
ultimately had to actually go and do it
but that was a terrible idea probably
[Laughter]
they could get directly to you they it's
like they had to go through layer after
layer but give them the email yeah you
gave the email you stretch and play a
different kind of character so you you
enjoy so you're you're you seems like
you're you're kind of semi naked you're
wearing this mask you're on a leash was
it funded was it fun to play this role
did you mean Demoiselle the most fun
that was actually oh my god the most fun
of that right there there's a says Danny
Brides leg right there and so he got the
good views yeah
money shot yeah yeah and and so I had
never met Danny bro and I felt like the
appropriate thing to do was to go into
his trailer and that outfit and
introduce myself by tackling him and
humping him on the bed we can ask on we
would never met Danny McBride before and
you burst into his trailer wearing the
mask semi-nude and you'd attacked him
mm-hmm
how did that go over not well really
really not well I think he was terrified
and like I think he was I didn't think
he liked me to this day it was Chris
hearing the recounting of the story yeah
like he was wearing a mask like Damien
know who I was Channing Tatum or
anything like that so there's like 11
o'clock at night because we were
shooting at night and this guy's seeing
this trailer reading a book and if that
comes into the room and tackles him and
holds him down to the ground right
that's some scary [ __ ] now there was
stuff that was so outrageous that it had
to be cut from the film that you're a
character like what kind of stuff were
you what because what you're doing in a
film is fairly outrageous what did they
cut out I guess we will never know I I
don't remember it very much to be honest
it was it was kind of an out-of-body
experience as soon as that mask went on
I don't know the [ __ ] just came out of
me I don't really remember it yeah okay
but very very bad stuff okay
the search for footage begins
you